now to the latest on Todd and Julie
Chrisley the reality stars received a
combined 19-year prison sentence for
bank fraud and tax evasion of 30 million
these were very serious crimes the fraud
was extensive and there was really no
remorse being shown what we will not do
is we will not break because God didn't
bring us this far to drop us off they
sought out the spotlight right at the
time that they knew
not paying their taxes in a year we
probably spend 300 000 sometimes more
just on clothe
as for where Todd and Julie will serve
time the judge recommended Julie be sent
to this Federal facility in Tallahassee
where Elaine Maxwell is serving time and
Todd goes to Pensacola hot bench judge
Rachel Juarez says it's about as good as
it gets it's a low security prison with
less than a thousand inmates and one of
the places that is sort of widely
recognized to be a little bit easier for
criminals to do time
Universal has not officially commented
on the future of the three Chrisley
reality shows but with Todd and Julie
Behind Bars you can bet they're over
however a source close to the show
Chrisley Knows Best tells E.T that the
network has some episodes of season 10
that were shot prior to the trial that
will Air next year
ET spoke exclusively with Todd and
Julie's daughter Savannah last week as
the family prepared for sentencing I've
never seen two people my parents be so
steadfast in their faith and in prayer I
may come home without both of my parents
and that's my new normal I come home
Tuesday and I have custody of the 16
year old and a 10 year old in her new
unlocked podcast Savannah wondered about
the future Chrisley attorneys requested
the sentences to be staggered in the
interest of the kids including 16 year
old Grayson who was recently
hospitalized after a car crash left his
pickup totaled
many of the victims here were Community
Banks in the Georgia area that have
since gone under I would expect the
restitution to be probably at least
seven to eight million possibly more
[Music]